my guest this week is the
self-proclaimed strangest animal of talk
radio and the host of louder with
Crowder steven crowder welcome to the
show thank you very much well I don't
proclaim that that's Gowens song but I
appreciate you attributing that lofty
price oh I'll take it I was told it was
self proclaimed we do some serious
research around here you've just allowed
it to become part of the lore yeah I
exactly I've allowed it and it's a I
don't even think we have the rights to
the music but I appreciate that you know
you started off as a comedian as did I
yet you do actual research and I feel
compelled to whereas a lot of other
media half the time I'm going like what
are none of you going to fact check this
what why am I the one to do this and I
see you're doing that a lot too so
regardless of politics you know I
appreciate it yeah well that is gonna be
sort of the thrust of everything we talk
about for the next hour because yes
whether we agree on everything or not is
irrelevant but I know you do do your
research and you fact-checked a lot of
things that I see in the media that are
nonsense and you do a great job with it
which is why I wanted to have you on and
I've been on your show and we're gonna
do a little something for you after this
this is cross-promotion the Palooza way
do a little something for me after huh
people listening he's going to come on
the show it doesn't matter with his
queer party friends no yeah no none of
that kind of stuff it's gonna we're on
skype but everyone's gonna stay close
okay let's start here so Crowder I know
a little bit about your history but for
the for the people that know nothing
about you first off you are in you're in
Michigan right now is that correct no
let's not talk about it my show is based
out of Michigan I don't need my
whereabouts disclosed gosh the problem
with live television yeah I was I was
born in Detroit raised in Montreal and
so I started acting at a young age 12
years old was doing voice work and TV
and sort of doing stand-up and my mid
teens which then brought me to New York
LA as soon as I was old enough to be in
a bar in the States and Canada came full
circle I was a young libertarian sort of
edgy I guess considered comic getting
banned from clubs and colleges and then
went to the Internet and then here we
are but yeah it all started out was
raised in Montreal acting stand-up that
was my bread and butter really up until
I was pulled into this
Karina at I want to say 21 at Fox News
yeah you know it's funny I also feel
like I was sort of pulled into this I've
always loved politics and I studied
politics in college but in this recent
incarnation in the last couple of years
I do feel like there's there's this pull
whether whether I like it or not but so
were you always into politics so you
were you were getting banned at clubs
what were you doing yeah colleges well
there was like her the first thing was a
multicultural fair and Muslims
complained and this was long before
Achmed the dead terrorist or any of that
you know if you watch I've done plenty
of material on Islam and I've made fun
of literally every single group of
politician on our program particularly
people subscribe to the podcast our
commercials are nothing but sketches and
parodies and so everyone no one is safe
there I just made a joke about some kind
of like a Muslim guy beating his wife I
don't know what it was I might have been
17 at the time beating his wife in order
to keep quiet about the fact that he
beat her and people got offended and
then Asians got offended because I had
some jokes about anime ever being young
just thinking this is this is comedy
right like some other guy just got up
talking about a three-way at a truck
stop and my stuff is relatively benign
it's it's offensive but it's not dirty
so it started with that and then just
meetings and back rooms you know with
Viacom and MTV and people saying you
really shouldn't be saying this so it
just sort of happened organically I was
always conservative because I was raised
in a socialist province
my parents were you know like yes well
you know what and that's true a lot of
people don't understand if you talk to
people who've left those places very
very few of them still support socialism
people who are in it who don't know any
better you'll probably get a lot of
Canadians who like their free health
care but once you have Canadians who've
experienced the quality of American
health care at best you'll get them
saying yeah the quality's better here
but I still liked the safety net of
Canada so starting with me as a kid you
know at 12 years old 13 years old making
pretty significant checks doing this
show Arthur at PBS I got to meet
Garfunkel when I was there and I was hit
during his phase when we were coached do
not mention Paul Simon some I'm a 13
year old kid like listen Art Garfunkel
is coming in don't ever say the name
Paul
Simon and it's not easy did you
you really didn't do a lot without the
Simon and my dad explained to me listen
this is your check
52% is going to be gone for rent what
done a list and as a kid but you know
that's my money I still have to make up
the time I left school to go to the
studio and so it developed pretty
organically and I do attribute it to a
good dad you know even though you and
him would disagree on a lot he always
encouraged me to answer questions and
think critically he didn't say you're a
conservative you're a Christian say why
do you believe this and you know
substantiate your claim and so there was
no moment of genius it just sort of
happened that way yeah and I know you
know this but I love talking to people
that I would disagree with I'd rather
talk to people that I would disagree
with but someone that's coming from a
principled place so like you for example
I mean I've seen you do things that many
of my friends on the Left would say are
incredibly offensive things things about
trans people or handicapped people or
Muslims or whatever else but to me your
style is sort of more the Seth
MacFarlane Family Guy style which is we
literally make fun of everyone period
and that's sort of the egalitarian way
of comedy that it should be done I think
yeah I don't I don't what have we done
about handicapped people I can't I mean
we have I'm sure I have no doubt but you
did that you were in the wheelchair I
actually had knee surgery oh that was I
thought well I know you had knee surgery
but I thought for Bernie no actually a
knee surgery and but now what you really
do really take comedy far that you go
ahead and have knee surgery just for the
bit that's commitment
well that was commitment that was a
journey for Bernie where's yeonggi
tunnel II went in for 9 hours at a
Bernie rally I mean you know at the end
of day it's either funny or it's not and
I know you'll get people in the comment
section go loser why conservatives can't
be funny I've never been of that school
I think Jon Stewart is hilarious one of
my favorite comedians is Kathleen
Madigan I think Bill Maher it can be so
horrendously unfunny it's unwatchable
because all he does is throw up his
hands and make a political statement
with that all these tea baggers let's
just hack to me sorry he can be funny
but when he does that you just need to
say okay your comedy hat is off and I do
like you do give them more leeway than
people who don't claim to be comedians
but it has to be funny and I do think
and I wrote about this at big Hollywood
back when I was you know an Andrew
Andrew Breitbart was a good friend
before it was Breitbart Shapiro myself
Adam Baldwin were some of the first
writers and I read about the Tina Fey
doctrine I said there's been a
noticeable shift in comedy and if you'll
see this on SNL where Tina Fey will
forego the funny joke deliberately to
push an agenda and she did that with
Palin and McCain during that election
cycle and it just it just wasn't funny
and that's my biggest issue with it
again
not that you can't do it you can do it
just be honest about it
I tell people all the time yeah I'm
pretty biased and every now and then I'm
going to use my platform to push an
agenda that I agree with and if I could
take coke brother money I'd have it on a
flava flav necklace with a spinning K
clock I would be gaudy about it I wish I
had all the special interest money
people claim that I do I don't but I
would take it if I could yes so that's
an interesting spot for for the comic to
be in because I do find in general that
comics you know from going back to Lenny
Bruce to George Carlin to Chris Rock to
anybody you know to Chapelle and anyone
that's doing any kind of edgy stuff
today we do find ourselves in a spot
where the the good ones we want to tell
the truth and we also want to be funny
and I think what you're saying is at
least in your view in the Tina Fey
situation or some of the SNL stuff it's
like the agenda overrode the funny and
but part of that just that it's a big
corporate operation over there right NBC
is owned by GE and you know there's
there's a paycheck I don't know about
all the corporate stuff I don't Lena
Dunham is horrendously unfunny and her
dad's she has a job because her dad drew
angry vaginas that's why Lena Dunham has
a job have you ever seen have you ever
googled Carroll Dunham no but her dad
I've never googled angry vagina believe
it or not no Google Carroll Dunham all
her father did was draw vent on all
Ford's spread angry vaginas when
we were on Joe Rogan Choi said Britain
he didn't believe this and bring it up
now just Google Carroll Dunham
more angry hairy vaginas than you could
and not like the woman have the woman
have no face
it's just vaginas and he was a famous
artist and that was a big reason for
Lena Dunham to get back to it and she's
not funny is a good example there are
plenty of women who are funny out there
she's not and she puts on this cloak of
it's because I'm a woman
it's because I'm fat it's because I'm
snaggletooth through I smell bad or
whatever it is that day that's the
newest form of discrimination that's my
issue if you go out there you let your
material stand and you take your licks
fine but that's not what comedians are
doing now and one thing that you haven't
run into Dave respectfully is yeah there
is a bias against people who are who are
to the right of center in the
entertainment industry I have no doubt
there is well I've no doubt there is an
um I can see already what's happening
with me even though I've never voted for
a Republican I've never considered
myself on the right the whole my whole
show is to try to save what I see with
the left and I know you're trying to
save the right so we'll get into some of
that in a sec but yeah I see people
trying to paint me as right now because
I don't fit into the the exact box that
they want on the left which is extremely
disappointing to say the least
no absolutely and you know but I think
you see this too like Chris Froome I
don't think Chris Rock is funny I think
Richard Pryor was hilarious Eddie Murphy
I've never thought Chris Rock was funny
I was there watching him backstage
because I was a seat-filler as a kid at
the Just for Laughs festival so twelve
thirteen he was coming out in his jeans
jackets I just didn't think he was funny
but he was talking about I won't do
colleges because of two PC but okay good
for you Chris Rock I understand it or
Sarah Silverman saying that then Sarah
Silverman comes out and says well you
can't say that's gay in a pejorative way
or Chris Rock says well you know black
kids are being shot no one and then they
want the social justice warrior PC
culture when it's convenient for them
and they deserve to be devoured by this
monster that they've created and I don't
just say this to blow smoke I know that
you don't do that but that is incredibly
wet rare so I mean I want when we get
into the mean wanting to save the right
and you at the left
I wonder what there is to save about the
left at this point because this has been
their path to destruction for decades
yeah well look I it's definitely been an
evolution with me seeing it for a while
and you know Milo did his best to
convert me to the right it didn't quite
work I'll give you an opportunity as
well you know the Sarah Silverman thing
I'm totally with you on that because her
whole career
was based on saying these outlandish and
offensive intentionally upsetting things
and then suddenly she backed now she
made it and then backtracked and said
well don't say these certain things and
it's like how did you build your whole
operation so how do you expect the young
guy how do you expect the next Sarah
Silverman to go ahead and be edgy when
now you as the once edgy person has set
up some new rules of operation raps
absolutely and when we wrote about that
extensively on Sarah Silverman you know
good examples is Bill burr
I think he's as good as any comedian
who's ever walked the planet of any
generation and he's not a political guy
but he's going up and he's saying things
that inherently our political now and
offending people and they get mad and
people protest he's just funny yeah it
doesn't mean that you you know you can't
be a political comedian I mean you do it
Kathleen Madigan does it from the left a
guy named Jeff Caldwell I find
hysterical and he's very far to the left
a Dennis Miller I'm not saying there's
only one type of comedian but Sarah
Silverman like you said made her living
off of that you know joking about
whatever was Ethiopian famine victims
and rape and and it was very very funny
it was very cutting edge at the time but
what's okay for her is not for you and
she wants to slam the door shut behind
her because all of a sudden she has
depression and she's made an indie film
about it and I just think that's horse
crap so basically you just want a sort
of consistent set of principles right I
mean is that really what's going on here
the way that you've been trying to talk
about what's going on on on the right
you just want that applied to comedy as
well because these people are talking
about real issues so you want them to be
consistent so if you're a liberal you
should be for a free speech right and
allowing people to be offended and all
that and that's what you've got you want
these guys to stand up for yeah but I
don't think liberal you know we use this
term and people get mad and so you know
they say anti-authoritarian and then
libertarian like you talk about my low
let me have these libertarians who
supporting Trump which is completely
indefensible I mean I am conservative I
am a Christian conservative they happen
about that but I would certainly if you
looked at my policies and put me on that
little quadrant without the bias
questions and that online questionnaire
I would be considered much more
libertarian like I'm a Christian so
pro-life absolutely because I believe
it's murder and I believe that's a
tenable position that's why atheists
have made it
States have the right to do whatever
they want I don't think drugs are good
but if States want to legalize pot that
want to legalize heroin fine and that
doesn't make me popular with
libertarians because they say well
that's a cop-out well now I have to
believe be consistent and believe in
states rights why why would a
libertarian say that's a cop-out cuz
aren't you saying go ahead and do it
what's the can personally vote to
legalize drugs I'm like on my steak
problem I don't know probably not if you
look at the results of Colorado I
probably just wouldn't wouldn't fill out
that voting ticket and they go oh then
you're not for personal liberty
listen you don't have to personally
support something to understand the
government's legitimate role
so yeah I'm personally a Christian
conservative I know I'll take take licks
for that I'm open about it but I would
be much more of a libertarian regarding
policy that's why the guy who I want to
be President is the guy who wants the
job the least you want the Ron Swanson
the guy who doesn't even believe the job
should really be doing all that much
that's what I want
you